two years ago I was asked by the new
company four or five four in New Haven
Connecticut whether I would like my
genomes sequenced by their new
technology and I said sure they can take
a sample of blood for me and get the DNA
from it the only thing I didn't want to
be told was what my gene for April
lipoprotein eat looked like because
that's prognostic for Alzheimer's
disease and so it might tell me
something about my next 10 years and
since we can't do anything about
Alzheimer's yet or not very much I
didn't want to know and then when they'd
actually got it they said you sure you
want to know all your jeans should we
remove knowledge from things which might
make you worried and I said no and then
the three weeks ago I suddenly was told
that I have mutations and in 25 genes
which are associated with disease in my
mutations or changes were at the spots
which would cause disease so I looked at
them and initially said you have one in
the breast cancer gene famous one which
wouldn't affect me but would effective
my niece has had it my sister had breast
cancer but we she was never tested they
might be at risk then I had someone else
look at that gene and they said my
change was in a place not known to be
associated with this ace so nonetheless
I'll called my nieces and say why don't
you get tested for black one